camille comment comment vous l'avez
trouvé comment vous l'avez trouvé votre
chronique à vous ma chronique
ouais sur une note 08 gérer 11
non je suis pas non chronique pas eu
peur ça allez quoi je pensais pas non
plus le feu mais mais ils en pensent
quoi votre frère ils en pensent quoi
votre frère mon frère françois
ouais et que du bien je partage abordés
on va lui demander
c'est là où tu es le père de camille ton
moral
j'ajouterai qu'il ait accepté là le
frère ça déconne pas là c'est
l'informaticien le frère de canal c'est
le cas vous appeler quand vous êtes
comme ça vous êtes alors bientôt c'est
quand votre prénom
terrorisés par les deux micros clément
reste un professionnel de la télé aussi
à laisser parler dans le micro besoin qu
ennahda appelle clémence le pea
l'informatique et des financiers il est
financier tout quoi sciences po vous
avez fait et ouais vous êtes fiers de
votre frère clément les chiens ils vont
ferrero d'offrir vous avez vous êtes son
frère aîné dans le micro tu peux dire à
tout faire qui pendent au micro hall a
fait venir
ça nous a coûté une tonne aujourd'hui
des coûts toile aujourd'hui avec tout ce
qu'on leur a donné on pas mettre la clé
sous la porte
alors arrêtez les gars ou des
professionnels ou land art et touche à
l'argent mais après qu'il a accepté vous
habitez ou paris parmi intra muros ou
non ces vincennes je te coûte d'accord
est très bien alors je suis coup d'envoi
ce que vous avez des petits dossiers sur
cabinda où deux dossiers quand même sur
camille combal vous avez pas vous avez
pas un petit truc sur lui voilà quand il
était jeune
est-ce qu'ils avaient du succès avec les
filles beaucoup c'est vrai la petite
fille toujours et avec les mecs vous de
nous dire
paris mais regardez là c'est quoi cette
photo put passer par mon frère
non mais c'est quoi cette chômage c'est
quoi cette photo la kadji dégueulasse
mais c'est c'est l'été quoi est-ce que
vous nous avez ramené des petites photos
sur camille paris qu'ils aient de la
magic amis quand il était petit ailleurs
c'est vrai ou pas c'est pareil qu'il
faisait de la magie les gars regarder un
épisode tunisien
regardez c'est bien parce que c'est la
honte d'un repas de famille mais à la
télé vraiment on verra bien que tu
risques ou pas sans doute les mois vous
avez clément il débarque à clément la
lumière rouge là tu parles d'un micro si
on va se faire défoncer les bons mais
vous à tous j'ai tout alors moi je suis
à droite et mon frère l'a regardé que
les mains gauches avant vous aviez les
oreilles vachement des collègues ma
faute
et en fait c'est le fils de gilles
verdez je suis le premier gardien capte
et tps star c'est non mais sans rire
hélas hélas vous étiez déguisé en kinder
pinguins mais ça vous va bien il était
mignon
il avait une petite fiancée quand il
était petit oui oui elle s'appelait
alors elle s'appelait sarah est épié
pouvez tout nous dire si vous pouvez
nous dire ait choisi de dire jean marc
dire la vérité et donc les morts
charlotte charles
tout le sens une idée mais celle là qui
redoute nous aujourd'hui et vous
entendez bien tous les deux c'est vrai
on s'entend super bien je crois et
j'espère en tout cas ça me fait plaisir
de voir les élus en vrai et j'ai un
cadeau pour vous lécher en plus vous
partez en vacances chez nous c'est
cadeau vous partez cet hiver aux
vacances comme ico valais central
morgan est bon car il ya un petit anneau
parce qu'il y aura des canaux pour tout
public public va recevoir le livre dieu
d'eric le livre officiel ont été sortis
on va l'offrir à ses qui s'effrite alors
il y aura les chéris merci le cas du
combat à l'entraînement camille merci
mon chéri bercy clément beatles et des
adversités mort très bon mais bon il est
prêt pour faire de la télé à bercy